foreign
[Music]
hey there and welcome to the step by
step for neon spinning cubes uh just to
show you really quickly what this is if
you follow my Instagram account or I
believe this is on Facebook as well
you'll probably would have seen this in
the past
um
it's really really simple it's three
3D cubes that are in the element of form
and they're just spinning and they're
looping and then there's a texture going
on
um in here I don't know if you can see
this or not there's a speckly texture
going on
um a grit and there's also some
displacement mapping going on on these
edges and of course there's chromatic
aberration which I always love so
um very simple effect to create done
with After Effects and Cinema 4D light
um so let me show you how to create this
simple version of form in After Effects
and just so you know this has gotten a
lot of great response from people that
see it
um it doesn't always have to be super
complicated to make really interesting
motion designs so this is a perfect
example of simple
simpler is better
so let's jump into after effects
so here we are inside of After Effects
and I'm going to create a different size
composition this time this composition
is going to be actually be 1080 by 1080.
call it spinning
Cube
and it's 1080 by 1080 because that's an
Instagram size for video
[Music]
um
we're just going to create this actually
for Instagram because that's what I
created for originally
um so this is a great example of how to
do that I'm going to leave it at 24
frames a second you could do multiple
different frame rates but we're also
going to make this 48 frames so two
seconds 24 frames a second 48 frames
that's two second it's going to be a two
second Loop
1080 by 1080 cool
okay so here we are so the very first
thing we're going to do I don't know if
you've ever worked with After Effects
and Cinema 4D but it's actually very
easy to do what you're going to see here
is it's actually going to open up a full
version of Cinema 4D but that's okay if
you have light which I originally did
this on it works exactly the same you're
just not going to see as many options
probably in your light version but what
we are doing can be done in light so
we're going to go to our timeline here
we're going to click on layer new and
we're going to go down to Maxon Cinema
4D file and we'll click that
and you have to save the Cinema 4D file
before it actually opens up Cinema 40.
so we will do that uh we'll just call
this
um
spinning cubes
and I'll save it
and it's going to launch Cinema 4D and
we're inside a Cinema 4D so like I said
yours may look slightly different you
may not have all these options up here
uh or around but that's totally fine
um what I'm going to show you is all in
Cinema 4D so
the first thing we're going to do is
because we're working in 24 frames a
second we need to make sure our project
settings are 24 frames per second if
this window is not open all you have to
do is go up to edit project settings and
it'll open up down here so we're going
to change this to 24.
and that's fine and dandy and you can
see here that uh the sides are slightly
darker and that's because this is what's
going to render this is the frame that's
going to render so we set up our After
Effects uh project to be
1080 by 1080. so we'll jump back into
Cinema
and we're going to go to this window
this little icon right here it's a
Clapper board with a settings icon you
just click that and it opens up render
settings and we're just going to change
it from 800 to 1080.
by and you can see that when you'll see
the window actually change its size as I
do this
1080.
cool so uh here's 1080 by 1080. it's
really weird
um when you render out you also have to
change the frame rate here to 24 frames
per second so that's all you have to do
you could change this to all frames
um but uh that's pretty much it
everything else will stay the same for
now
so we'll close that down and we're going
to create a cube so you can do that by
clicking here
or you could go to create and we'll go
to create object Cube and I'm not going
to mess with any of these settings I'm
just going to keep it exactly how it is
and the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to go up here to this little
array icon and we'll go to atom array
click that
and then we're going to drag the cube
into the atom array so you just click on
the cube drag and see how the little
arrow turns from left to down when it's
down that means it's going to put this
Cube underneath the atom array as a
child
and so I'll let go and you can see that
it moved underneath here and it also
changed
to this um
atom array right which is these tubes
and these spheres
um so all we have to do now is just
click again on atom array
object and we're just going to change
the cylinder radius to one
and the sphere radius to one
and there we go there is our cube right
simple enough
okay always do now is create a texture
to tell this Cube what color we want it
to be so
um I think for my original I did Red to
start but it really doesn't matter so we
just go to create new material and
there's our material and we just click
and we drag you could drag it on top of
the object here or you could drag it
over here to the atom array but there it
is he's now it's white so I can double
click and here it is opened up
um I actually like to go back to my
texture double click and it opens up a
new window where I can see all of the
different uh
properties of the texture which they
don't show up over here
I'm not really sure why
[Music]
um
once I activate them they'll actually
show up here so if I activate
illumination
you can see it popped up right there so
that's what we want we want illumination
luminance I'm sorry so we'll turn off
color and we'll turn off reflectance
okay I guess the theory you could leave
color instead of luminance and just
color turn color all the way to White
because you can see the color defaults
to like a gray
um but it still kind of has you know it
has this Shadow to it right in the
preview well luminance does not do that
luminous 100 white so if I want to make
this actually let's just go with
something different here Let's do let's
do pink I've been really into pink and
purple lately it's probably because my
daughter
um but yeah there's our pink
uh cube right
so
doesn't do anything so one more quick
setup let's jump back into after effects
if I'll hit command tab on the Mac
and it brings up all my icons I'll go to
cinema oh sorry After Effects
um
here we are back in After Effects and
remember we set this to a duration of 48
frames per second and see how this is
our 3D
Cube from Cinema 4D and it's way longer
than 48 frames per second so we need to
make the timeline
match so we'll take this to 48 frames
per 48 frames
and you notice in After Effects there's
nothing here right there's no cue why is
there no Cube because we have haven't
actually saved this version again we
saved it when we started but there's no
there was no cube when we started so
we'll hit command s
to save and we'll jump back into after
effects and Watch What Happens
boom there it is okay
um it's obviously a low res version
um it's a preview version because if you
go over here into After Effects you're
going to see render settings right so
when you create a Cinema 4D object in
After Effects it automatically puts uh
the Cinema 4D object in your timeline
and then it applies this Effect called
cineware and cinewear is what links
um the Cinema 4D object to After Effects
so
um if I change renderer from software to
standard final standard is the renderer
final is the final preview
there you go
so um these all these different
functions can do a lot of different
things I'm not going to get into that
especially in this particular lesson
since we're just now jumping into Cinema
I know some of you have some Cinema 4D
experience and some of you don't so I'm
keeping this very very basic for right
now so let's jump back into Cinema
and let's animate this
so how do we animate this well it's
pretty simple it's just like keyframes
in After Effects
um what we're going to do is I'm going
to actually rename this to large Cube
and we'll go ahead and close that and
all I have to do
is actually before this before we
animate it let's do this let's copy
which is command C command V to paste or
you could do copy and paste right here
pretty simple we'll call this
um
medium
Cube
and then we'll copy this and we'll paste
again and we'll call this small oops
small cube
and I like to keep things in a nice tidy
fashion so it'll go from the biggest to
medium to small
okay so we're going to open up medium
we're going to click on that Cube and
under object here you see the size is
set to 200 by 200 by 200. they're all
set to 200 by 200 by 200 because we
copied and pasted so I'm just going to
reduce this middle one to half the size
which would be 100 by 100
by 100
so there we do we have a cube inside of
the other Cube and then I'll open up the
small cube and I'll make this one
oh I think before I did 25 of
across the board instead of 50. so we'll
try 25
25. and all I'm doing is hitting tab on
my keyboard to move from one property to
the next to the next to the next so for
whatever reason the 25 worked better
than the 50.
I liked so
okay so
um in my original
um concept what I thought about doing
was actually transforming or rotating
each of these cubes individually
to come up with something unique what I
did not what I ended up doing actually
was I actually grouped these three
together and I animated that by itself
so all I have to do to do that is just
select all three hopefully I'm not going
too fast for you guys here
um
and
group object or alt G so when I group
them it creates a null just like after
effects really simple so we'll just call
this cubes
right
I actually want to
move that over but I can't
for whatever reason but that's okay
so all I have to do now is
believe I animated on the pitch
so I just click
set a keyframe for pitch and I go down
my timeline several ways you can do this
I can click I can drag I can go to the
end with this
button here
all different ways just go to the enter
timeline and go to 180 degrees
and I click again see how there's a
yellow circle there because there's no
keyframe so if I click again
boom
so now if I play back
you can see it rotates but you can
already see a problem because see how it
starts
Cinema 4D defaults to a bezier
on the curves on the speed speed curves
the F curves
um whereas you know after effects I
guess it does default to bezier as well
and my preferences on After Effects I
actually change it to linear
um that's a whole different story so all
I have to do is
um I can right click
on cubes and I can go down
to
show F curves
and it opens up this window if that
doesn't work for you you can still
highlight cubes you can go over here to
window and go to timeline F curve
and if you don't see all the keyframes
you just right click in this window and
do a frame all or you can hit h
or you can go up here and let's see
where is that at
frame all
and it does not show it there it is
let's do that again I had to highlight
the word Cube I didn't know what to
frame so frame all so really simple I
can just click and drag to highlight
both keyframes and go right here to
linear you can see that it defaults to a
spleen let's click watch what happens
when I click linear here
so see now it's a constant Loop
pretty simple
um one other thing I did is I actually
changed the bank I believe the 45
degrees so let's see what happens here
yeah so see that actually made the
animation more interesting right
so instead of just being straight on
well so I'm quite straight on there but
uh you can mess around with the Angles
and just give it something well they're
straight on which is not nearly as
interesting
[Music]
um
as either this angle or even this angle
I think I like this a little bit better
but so that's essentially all you have
to do inside of Cinema 4D we could take
it even further we could individually
now animate each of these cubes so that
you know right now if you look at their
keyframes they're not doing anything
right the null for the group is spinning
on the pitch so I could theoretically
set a keyframe
for well let's do the small cube now
actually let's do the medium Cube the
one in the middle and I could set a
keyframe here I could go to the end and
set another keyframe again uh to 180
degrees
hit a keyframe right click Animation
Show F curve make sure these are set to
linear and just see what this looks like
so it's a little more interesting it
actually starts to get a little more
almost kind of confusing
uh to my eye
um something I might try here is I might
try
the medium I might try and just go 90
degrees
see what that looks like instead oops
see they were all highlighted there so a
keyframe was set for all of them
so let's change this to 90 degrees
and we're still linear cool let's see
what this looks like
I don't know that might work
let me try and set this bottom one now
from zero
to 90.
right click Animation Show F curve
highlight the two keyframes
linear so this looks like
foreign
I don't know that I absolutely love it
something I might try to do now really
quickly is just go back to the original
and do a negative 90.
it's all about experimentation right
show F curve just to make sure sometimes
I'm doing this because sometimes when
you set a keyframe it'll go back to a
spleen again for whatever reason
now I don't know if you guys notice a
difference to me this looks better at a
negative 90.
um so the next thing I'd try is I would
then go to the last small cube and try
it at negative 90 as well
so keyframe
um I don't like that so I actually like
it
had a positive
foreign
yeah I don't know
I feel like it's still too much going on
sometimes it can be a little too much
going on so let's just
um let's actually take this keyframe out
animation delete track
so now it's just a little Cube
that's has these has a little bit extra
movement and I like that I'm cool with
that it looks pretty good
so uh last step here I'm going to
command s to save or go to file save
and it should have updated
um in After Effects I can actually
preview this
here's standard draft this will move a
little bit quicker
um
sometimes you'll see a huge change in
the quality other times you won't this
one doesn't make a huge difference okay
so there we go so now it's moving
um inside of After Effects it's form
it's 3D it's looking cool right so now
let's take it to the next level and I'll
show you what I did
so we're going to add a couple of
adjustment layers here
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to change this up a bit
we're going to add
um
glow edges
let's see what that looks like
that's pretty cool
so this is a little bit different than I
worked that I did the first time I used
a straight up glow at time but I like
this I also um to the 3D object I
actually applied a gradient which I
believe I just did a gradient ramp
yeah so the default is actually um
pretty cool
[Music]
right there I like the color of that so
very simple
um
from this to this by just adding a ramp
it's just that that little subtle detail
um you know just giving it so it's not
solid a solid same color all the way
around there's this little subtlety in
the color that your eye will notice when
you're watching it
um your eyes not gonna automatically
most people who aren't artists won't
pick that up immediately but they'll
they'll just look at it and say well
there's something about that that I my
eye really likes well it's just these
subtleties right that I always talk
about so a simple gradient
uh makes quite a bit of difference
and then I also added my favorite which
is uh noise
over the top of this I need to add a
background so we can see the noise
so we'll try that as a dark
sometimes I like to use pure black
sometimes I don't and this is not pure
black
so noise on top of the the glow and
noise beneath the glow which I kind of
like the noise beneath the glow
and this glue is a little bit too strong
for me
less is more right less is more so with
without
with without so the glow is giving its
color the gradient is creating this uh
brighter white to dark
the glow is giving it that pink color
which I like
so and then you can always finish this
off with a little bit of a chromatic
aberration which I love which I think I
did use before let's just look I don't
know if it's necessarily on this
necessary on this version
[Music]
um
oh gosh
I just love it it's always so cool
just that retro Vibe that's going on so
of course we have to use that right
right
um yeah and I did do a displacement map
which I'll show you how to do that
really quickly we're just going to
import some footage in and bring it in
here
Vision here I can't remember off the top
of my head if this was a Creative
Commons footage or if it's footage I
actually paid for so I'll have to check
into that one before if if it's not here
in the project file there are so many
places you can go go to YouTube you can
you know search VHS footage and you can
download a multitude of different
footage to use and this kind of stuff so
but what I did is I turned it off
um I believe I locked it I went back to
my spinning cubes I said let's distort
with a displacement map
and that's already kind of crazy
and we changed the displacement layer to
the VHS layer
all right and
let's see here
yeah so see it's very subtle
but it works for me right so subtlety is
more less is more right so there you go
there's the spinning Cube from Cinema 4D
to After Effects it's a really cool loop
that you can do a lot with
um I love Loops I've been really getting
into like gifs and things like that
lately so this is how you do it very
simple hope you learned something new
leave a comment let me know and I look
forward to seeing what you guys create
in the Facebook group so see ya